it depends how you view it right like
some people want their kids to just be a
I had a girl on her show that didn't
want she doesn't want any teacher
talking to her kid because she doesn't
want anyone else to influence the
children other than the family but then
her children will find it difficult to
be in the outside world in real reality
you know I you know I used to think like
that but you know I have cousins and
they're like the most sheltered like
they're all homeschooled and they're so
guys you don't even know like we always
thought they were like the crazy
Catholic Family because it was like the
dad like wouldn't let her show her knee
it was like that you know but the kids
turned out so good like they're all
really smart
um they all are normal like it's you'd
be surprised